وفي لندن قالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان
بريطانيا قامت بتدريب 19 الف جنديان
اوكراني واضافت في تغريده ان 9000 منهم
عادوا بالفعل الى بلادهم
ومعهم
155,000 عده ما بين اسعافات اوليه وحمايه
ومقاومه للشتاء
ونقلت صحيفه تايمز البريطانيه عن جنرال من
بريطانيا قوله ان عناصر من مشات البحريه
البريطانيه شاركوا في عمليات سريه في
اوكرانيا ضمن بيئه شديده الحساسيه وفي
مهامه تنطوي على درجه عاليه من المخاطر
السياسيه والعسكريه
كما اعلنت الخارجيه البريطانيه في تغريده
انا ليس الوزراء البريطاني اعلن حزمه دعم
للدفاع الجوي لاوكرانيا بقيمه 50 مليون
جنيه استرلي
واضافت الخارجيه البريطانيه ان حزمه
المساعدات الجديده لاوكرانيا تتالف من مئه
وخمسه وعشرين مدفعا مضاده للطائرات
وتكنولوجيا لمواجهه مسيرات الايرانيه
الفتاكه